after years of fundaman's director Zack
Snyder's court of justice league and
probably got released in 2021 but that
wasn't the end of the controversy two
years later a joke in the Barbie movie
brought the discourse back warning
spoilers for Barbie ahead director Greta
gerwig's Barbie was always going to be a
lightning rod an Unapologetic look at
how hard it can be to exist as a woman
in a patriarchal society Barbie is going
to be divisive as its rollout continues
but one joke in the movie in particular
is causing more trouble than you might
think that said gerwick herself was
bracing for it ahead of the movie's
release she said that she wasn't quite
prepared for what would come of that one
line nonetheless she kept it in the
movie anyway to explain a bit Barbie and
Ken leave Barbie land for the real world
and discover that as men who hold the
highest positions of power there the
opposite of how Barbie land Works
basically everything that men do in your
world women do in ours Ken is fascinated
by the idea of patriarchy he returns to
Barbie land on his own and transforms it
into Kingdom when Barbie finally comes
back and brings our new friends Gloria
and her daughter Sasha they find the
other Barbies all of whom held
high-ranking jobs completely subservient
to the Kens after being stabbed out of
her Kennedy's Funk writer Barbie can't
believe what's happened to her but
that's where the Snyder cut comes in
writer Bobby says that she felt like she
fell asleep and got really invested in
director Snyder's curse of Justice
League drawing her induced stupor it's a
pretty benign and honestly pretty funny
joke but people on the internet really
don't like it when others take Zack
Snyder's name in vain gerweg and obvious
students of Pop Culture law and
co-writer Noah bombach skewer a lot more
than Zack Snyder's Justice League and
Barbie in the very same section of the
movie president Barbie helps a fellow
Barbie out after she's been deprogrammed
insisting that one of the Ken's show her
Francis Ford Coppola's classic The
Godfather not only that she specifically
asked that he talked through the entire
movie and explain it to her distracting
him while the Barbie he held hostage has
shown the light he has pretty unlikely
Gerwig and bomback actually think the
Godfather and Zack Snyder's Justice
League or bad movies and deserve
derision that's not what the joke is
about it's not the expense of the cans
and their bloated sense of
self-importance spending all that time
explaining movies to various captive
Barbies gerwig's film is Rich with
references to other movies and pop
culture properties and while only a few
are shouted out directly it doesn't come
from a place of tearing them down you
can go back to your regular life or you
can know the truth about the universe
even so fans of Snyders upon hearing
there might be one joke about their
favorite director jumped online before
the movie even came out to defend his
honor on July 19th two days before
Barbie hit theaters one wrote so Greta
Gerwig is desperately trying to position
Barbie as a feminist Blockbuster but the
fact that the movie takes shots at Zack
Snyder the leader of third wave
Hollywood feminism leads me to Delta's
storytelling capabilities another agreed
writing saying Bobby is being popular
for decades yet they have to find a way
to make a dig about Zack Snyder his fans
his cut out of spite as usual Stay
classy WB just a note to both Barbie and
Zack Snyder's Justice League are
distributed by Warner Brothers after
seeing the movie others chimed in to
defend Barbie without insulting Zack
Snyder's Justice League one commented
yes Bobby directly references Zack
Snyder and his Justice League Noah isn't
distasteful nor and funny it's actually
very funny it's a great joke and the
audience went pretty crazy at it nobody
is gonna like Zack Snyder's Justice
League any less after Barbie so honestly
all's well that ends well the joke was a
bold move on gerwick's part though it
makes sense since Bobby is a pretty bold
movie overall